star wars jedi fall in order is one of
the rare star wars games that feels
right at home in the franchise's greater
story
it's a more grounded take on being a
jedi and its well-rounded characters
help tell a compelling story that makes
it feel true to the star wars universe
okay shut that thing off and grab some
seed
friendship is a major theme of star wars
and the core of jedi fallen order is the
relationship between protagonist kal
kestis and his faithful droid companion
bd1
the jedi and his droid spend the entire
game together as they explore vast
interlocking maps spread across several
different worlds with cal and bd
constantly conversing and assisting one
another
healing stim you're full of surprises
bd is a main component of the story he
contains the information
that helps cal to complete his mission
of finding a list of force sensitive
children spread across the galaxy
but bd is also a big part of gameplay
providing support like stims for healing
opening doors and navigating zip lines
which make him an essential companion
you'll need bd's help both in and out of
combat because fall in order can be
punishing
it borrows liberally from soulsborne
games enemies do a lot of damage and
require careful execution of blocks and
parries to defeat
often testing both your lightsaber
combat skills and your tactical use of
force abilities
you can only replenish bd's stims at
specific locations that serve as
checkpoints
but like in the souls games healing
yourself at these points respawns all
the enemies in the area
and while you can gain experience points
for defeating enemies and gathering
collectibles that allow you to unlock
new abilities
dying costs you most of what you've
earned requiring you to find
an exact revenge on the enemy that
bested you in order to get it back
but while fallen order takes a lot from
the souls games it's by no means as
challenging
instead it strikes a strong balance
between making you a skilled jedi
warrior
and keeping you from becoming an
all-powerful force superhero
that balance makes jedi fall in order
feel grounded and believable
and it helps make the empire a more
menacing dangerous threat throughout the
game
combat focuses heavily on blocking
parrying and dodging
since enemies can do a lot of damage in
a single hit you have a stamina meter
that dictates how many blows you can
deflect without taking damage before
you're staggered and left open
fighting tougher enemies like the jedi
hunting purge troopers is often about
whittling down their stamina and
avoiding attacks so you can get in a few
good hits before backing off
you also unlock more powers as you work
through the game which adds a more
tactical element to fights
because fallen order often has you face
several enemies at a time
you'll need to figure out how you can
dispatch tougher foes quickly or whittle
down a crowd to keep from getting
overwhelmed
taken together all these elements often
mean fights consist of a mix of twitch
skills and strategic decisions
testing all of your abilities so you can
make sure to get out of a battle in one
piece
the difficulty of fallen order isn't
always perfectly tuned
it can be a frustrating game at times it
likes to throw handfuls of enemies at
you
often ambushing you before you know
they're there and the fact that they do
a lot of damage can mean things go belly
up after one cheap shot
infrequent checkpoints can make some
fights a pain
especially when you're facing off
against tough bosses and have to travel
a good distance to return to a fight
you'll try
over and over again but for the most
part fallen order does well to combine
the fantasy of being a jedi with a world
and enemies
that feel dangerous and imposing
especially in the second half though
fallen order really hits a stride as it
develops more force abilities give you
tools that make combat encounters
exciting while the story builds on the
relationships between cal
bd and their allies seer and greece as
they explore new aspects of the star
wars world
at the heart of the story is cal's
trauma from surviving order 66 the
empire's purge of the jedi during
revenge of the sith and how he and other
characters sort through their feelings
is some of the best stuff in the game
it's in the story and characters that
fallen order really shows that respawn
understands the essence of star wars
and while the story is a little rough in
its early hours rushing to get you on
your quest without establishing why you
should care
by the end it becomes an emotional and
rewarding journey
you know i've been alone for a while now
[Music]
without any purpose just
hiding
[Music]
there's no way to live not for a jedi
or a droid and that's ultimately what
makes fallen order work
not that it gets the sound of
lightsabers and blasters right but that
it understands that the franchise is
about knowing yourself
facing your darkness and overcoming
adversity with the help of your friends
jedi fallen order creates one of the
best star wars experiences in years
because it's willing to make being a
jedi difficult not just in dueling with
your lightsaber
but in finding your way in the galaxy
you